starting and uh
he's done well against the twins he has
a 2-1 record in three starts but coming
off an outstanding performance against
the tigers
three pitches garver
is retired and that's how this ball game
gets started
[Applause]
crews chased the pitch in the dirt and
that's the strikeout
so a couple of strikeouts in the first
inning for sean manaya well this is
brought to you in part by the work of
the heater you throw that fastball you
get nelly to fight that fastball off a
few times and then you throw a changeup
in the middle of the zone down
matt shoemaker and he's had a couple of
good starts for the twins this year the
shoemaker featuring the fastball slider
curveball
and a split change as i like to call it
been throwing a lot more four-seam fast
balls
top of the zone
olson keeps his hands low extends his
arms and the 2-2 pitch is lined to first
caught by cino
and that's out number three
a's don't score they do leave one twins
commit an error tough lefty on the mound
but
mitch moore knows how to hit
hit to right field
going back
rooker at the wall and that baby is gone
make it four
so mitch moreland
his first home run as a member of the
athletics it's a two-run shot to give
the a's the two-to-nothing lead
we just got to put it out there in the
universe talking about great abs
from mitch marlin
and he gets a splitter just kind of
hanging out
right in the middle of the zone foot
down on time
pack your bags
all aboard
next stop
pound down
and a pitch
and that was pulled down the left field
line that could go to the wall and it's
gonna get there cannon gonna pick it up
throw back into second but it's gonna be
a
stand up double for garver and the twins
have a base runner here in the
top half of the third inning so there it
is again there's that garber in that
number one spot danny not so much that
first at bat he strikes out a lot but
then that second time
in that number one spot that's when he
delivers
that's to left field down for a hit
garber will check in at third base so a
bullet to left
and donaldson's reached both times and
they'll put two men aboard for nelson
cruz
it was always a good sign when you have
a guy on base in front of the
three two three and four hitter that
just have been just killing
left hand pitching
here's the 1-0 spongana popped up right
center field not very deep charging in
piscotty along with
loriana piscotti makes the catch no tag
from third as steven hustles the ball
back in
get up there duplicate that same pitch
you get yourself another swing and miss
it's just about making this pitch
competitive and presentable somewhere
near the strike zone
and boxton chases it and that'll do it
nice job by sean manaya to get out of
the jam he's not a real hard thrower but
good control moves the ball in and out
but he just has not been able to stay
healthy and miguel
had
six seven maybe eight attempts to pick
it up and he couldn't do it
it was
nothing more than being able to pick it
up and turn around and step on the back
and he just could not pick it up clean
you know guys i'm surprised he quit on
it
[Applause]
one
and two
big double play turn lariano gains third
base ostidio with a long backflip and he
hit polanco right on the back that could
be a huge
play for the twins
jamaica was able to make a pitch get
olson to ground the ball in to the
second baseman
austinio made a great flip to polanco a
great relay over to miguel ceno
molonco just barely getting the runner
at first the numbers the twins i think
to set five double headers last year
that you mentioned in the ten games
nelson cruz went off i mean he had an
unbelievable ten games
fastball at 92 miles an hour and that's
five strikeouts for mania inside with
the target upstairs with the pitch even
though not inside but it was upstairs at
92 and
ceno just could not catch up to it
moreland hitting his
16th home run in his career at the
coliseum and the o2 swung on a drill
deep right center field that's on its
way heading toward the wall and it is
gone
off the state farm sign
and a second home run for mitch moreland
doing all the heavy lifting today it's
three-nothing oaklet
[Music]
and both times on two strike pitches
[Applause]
mistakes made by shoemaker
and moreland made him pay well you know
he's not afraid to hit with two strikes
and that's a gift
like the ball that he hit that
eventually won the game
two strikes on sunday
that one jumped out of here in a hurry
so that's going to lower the bases and
here comes olson who rounded into a
double play is
last time up he's over two today
and that one is launched down the right
field line but it is
it's grand slam hit the foul pole
it somehow stayed fair hit the foul pole
and that is the big hit the a's have
been looking for it's a grand slam by
oli
so the a's today with the first player
with a multi-home run game the first
grand slam of the season for the
athletics
and you're right holy got that big
three-run home run in houston on the
last road trip the big hit the a's we're
waiting for and
this afternoon cleared the bases with
this
[Applause]
he struck him out nasty pitch took a lot
off 83 miles an hour
[Applause]
that's from the fastball lasted bat when
he got the the double hit garber and
this time went soft got him way out in
front garver who a powerful young man
that's your prototypical leadoff hitter
but he can take
crews to lead it off strikeout and a fly
ball to right for cruz
fouls it back
we had a nice play
on the move
reaching
[Applause]
[Music]
with a nice pitch and that is his
seventh strikeout
and that one is drilled to left
cannas right there so well struck ball
by rooker
that is the second out so one more out
to go for sean manaya when you pitch a
no-hitter you pitch a perfect game you
know what the ninth inning is about or
in this case the seventh inning the
final inning
cap slowly to elvis andreas flips to
second and that is the ball game so the
a's stay high no surprise there they are
just doing everything well right now as
a team